john voigt is one of the most famous
actors in hollywood he's been famous for
more than 50 years so he sat and he's a
conservative
a ton so we just would talk to him about
what it's like to be conservative
in hollywood and that conversation
lasted about a minute and then it turned
into the direction of him
and his faith and what that's meant to
him in his life was not something we
expected to talk about
at all but we're glad we did the full
conversation on tucker carlson uh today
on fox nation but here's
part of it
[Music]
i was in a lot of trouble at one point i
had a divorce had some problems
and and i was in this little
house that i had
and i was really suffering
for many reasons my career was a little
bit influx at that time and
lots of things were going on my
relationship to my kids and
my wife and stuff
and i was on the on the floor i found
myself on the floor
saying it's so
difficult it's so difficult
i said it out loud and i heard
in my ear it's supposed to be difficult
you imagine can you imagine like a
separate voice telling me that
it's supposed to be difficult a voice of
wisdom kindness
you know clarity i mean
it had so much resonance this voice what
a message
it's supposed to be difficult can you
imagine
i mean this is it and i will boom
what i
and i got up and it would
and i can tell you tucker that moment in
time at that time i knew i said
you know what it meant was i'm not alone
yes everything is known everything is
known
i am known that's what it meant to me
whoa this is
did you expect it were you calling out
for god what
do you expect to know but not be out
now now i have to proceed with my life
right
so so i i but i felt tremendous energy
it's something somebody's rooting for me
it's like
don't give up it's it's like you know
there's a purpose here
you know you've got some ways you got a
ways to go son
you know what i'm saying whatever it
whatever you might imagine it meant it
meant
do you see and i and i got and i felt
great
and so then that and the next morning
uh and i i i'm not a person who
really prays with the idea that
anybody's listening
up to that moment now i know we're
covered man
everything we think everything we say
everything
it's you're known you know like they say
that god
knows every bird that falls yes
this is us two kids we all are known
we're being observed and helped and
loved
and we're we're expected to get up
and you know do battle
do something do what's right whatever it
is you see
there's a purpose here and the purpose
here is to learn our lessons and grow
and to and what's the big deal to give
to each other
you know to uh to be here to be of help
i mean this is what you figure out but
anyway then at that moment i was just
interested in me surviving
and so the next morning i get up i say
what do you got for me today
and i said turn on the radio
and here's what came up i swear this is
what happened when i turned the radio on
having some fun i'm having fun you know
to me because i'm i'm not taking myself
too seriously but it's serious
i turn on the radio it says i'll build a
stairway
to paradise with a new step
every day what
it's another one wait a minute i mean
what's going on here anyway i had that
kind of thing going on
for several days you know things were
happening to me
and then i started i was kind of
drawn to certain things from that point
on and uh
and i've had many many experiences but
that was that was the beginning so
that's the moment when you realize that
god's real knows you and is on your side
right what were the implications of that
well i had to straighten out
if i'm going to be a vessel for god i
mean i better be
cleaner than i was you know what i mean
i better be
a righteous fellow how hard was that
well you know i i've always had good
examples in my life my dad as i said was
a very righteous man my mother
and and i've had many good people in my
life so
uh i just got off track a little bit and
i realized that at that time and
so i worked worked since then to
be a better fellow what did it do for
your joy levels
for the way you feel every day that's
interesting
uh you know i said some
just a couple of days ago i was asked
about something and i said
then i have fear of the lord you know
they say have fear of the lord yeah
i got it i am really afraid
i'm afraid of offending
god right because
god is everything god is love god is you
know
all these beautiful things beauty
everything
and i'm going to how can i live up to
that
i need a lot of help but uh
i think that's the fear of the lord it
keeps you on the track you know what i'm
saying
it's a it's not a fear of uh
frightened of getting uh
you know attacked by anything it's a
fear of
offending fear of not living up to
yes the fear of doing the wrong thing
you know
of making a terrible mistake so
all of that you know but i've i've been
a happier fellow
i'm a much happier i mean i'm a satis
i may not look like it right now i don't
know what i look like but i'm a happy
fellow
john voight what a conversation when god
speaks to you it's not you're great
good job it's it's supposed to be
difficult
think about that ever since that
conversation went on for nearly an hour
talked about a lot of things it was
great the full episode is
on foxnation.com right now i'm steve
ducey
i'm brian kilny and i'm ainsley earhardt
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis